and hello hello today is gonna be a very lazy day i was
actually very tempted to like uh take the entire week off um
because uh last week and the week before that the last two
weeks was like took a lot of my social battery i was not i
was not like there as a person after after sunday back to
back to back to back of like interactions with a lot of new
people so by and like also like a lot of like old friends
and my social battery was was like maxed out like I am
producer I am an introvert so I was like a fucking exhausted
by Sunday and then because like you'll be like oh it was
Saturday you know that's then you got rest I was like no I
on Sunday I also had another I had another sponsor collab
with Shibidoki.
so after that, my battery was like just gone.
I was like 0%.
Like, it's like flashing.
Like, stop.
Stop.
Like, the battery's gonna fucking explode.
If you charge it anymore.
so, but instead I decided to make this week more so of like,
you know, stuff I sort of wanted to play.
I want you guys to know, it was so hard to decide like, um
what to do on saturday because i just wanted to play games
that i just wanted to play and not actually like try but so
i was just like oh like i was like oh i've always wanted to
play the shadow game but like but i know you i know the
sonic fans are gonna yell at me but it's a game i've been
i've always wanted to play because i wanted to like shoot i
wanted to shoot a gun you You know, like that's the only
thing I know about the shallow hedgehog game You got like
you give him a gun and then you save the president That's
the only one I that's the only thing I remember I've never
played the game before so but I know I know I can already
feel it They'll be like what are you doing Doki?
I've never seen someone so bad at a Sonic game.
Yes, you have It will be on Saturday.
Yes, you have you're going to You are going to and it's
gonna be on Saturday So I could I can feel it I can feel I
can feel the typing going on Yes, we will The thing is I've
never really I didn't grow up with Sonic games too I didn't
grow up with Sonic games so like I always like whenever I
play a Sonic game It like always confuses me because only
Sonic games play like Sonic games like you don't get like
any other no other skill is transferable to a sonic game
because it's like you gotta go fast but like it's so fast
like i'm for some reason i'm never ready to go fast it's
just so fast but yet the whole premise is you gotta go fast
like
fun stop thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
hey ducky oh you're able to get the rival's new venom kick
MVP animation his cake is sweet thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you uh yeah I have yeah for those who don't
know uh tomorrow is uh the new anniversary the first year
anniversary for Marble Rivals and they were like releasing I
don't know if it was leaks I think I don't know I think it
was like either leaks or official uh official like uh skin
teasers for the new anniversary and uh one of them is venom
shaking his booty Okay, but like, that's not part of the
skin.
But the whole idea is that the new skin, the skin theme for
the first year anniversary is like sweets and baked goods.
And like, Venom is in it.
And he's literally a giant fucking candy.
And the whole thing is about Venom's cake.
And he starts shaking his booty and stuff.
Well, I'll show you guys.
It was all over my feed.
But I think the one, the really the cutest one is Jeff in
business.
a business suit because it's also a free skin and we love
free skins uh it's it is oh it is from the official account
okay because i saw other ones i saw like uh animation stuff
from other other accounts so i wasn't sure because you know
the rivals leaked account and stuff so i wasn't sure if it
was from the official one or the the leaked info one um but
they also have i think the other one i think the jeff one
was my favorite because um it's really funny because you
know how they always love to pit uh marvel rivals and
overwatches to each other so Overwatch has this thing called
mythic skins where you customize your skin based on how much
you level it up so you can like have like oh I want this
part of the skin I want this part of the skin I want that
part of the skin um so next so tomorrow they're releasing
business chef which is basically a mythic skin for free So
people were like, oh, they're releasing a mystic skin for
free.
What is Overwatch going to do about it?
Oh,
so that's why people were like, whoa, what are they going to
do about it?
Yeah, it's actually really cool.
Let me see if I can find it.
Jeff, business.
I actually really like it.
It's so cute.
Let's see.
Where is it?
Where the fuck is the customization of the business skin?
Okay, but his intro is also really fucking cute too.
God damn it.
Where is it?
He's getting a free business Jeffskin that's customizable.
Yeah, he is.
Oh, yeah, here.
Wait.
Let me see.
Is this the one?
Yeah, yeah, this one.
So you can see here that you can see him.
You change his outfit and everything.
and it's all for free too so that's why people were freaking
out about it and um i don't i don't know if i could talk i
mean i guess like i'll hint something rivals told invited me
to something and they said it'll be just look at time square
tomorrow tomorrow on marvel rivals when the anniversary
update comes in check out time square If they added it,
they, you'll, maybe, maybe you'll find something.
If they did it, then I don't know.
Not real time.
Don't fly to New York City.
I don't mean real time square.
Just boot up the game.
Guys, don't book a ticket right now to time square.
I meant the in-game time square.
In-game, in-game, guys.
my way to new york city right now but um um um i don't know
i'm not sure if i'm not in it then if i mean if it's not
there then like uh i guess it included but i don't know
maybe i don't know i have no confirmation on whether or not
something is added tomorrow tomorrow um on the marble rivals
um on the marble rivals time square uh instructions unclear
booked flight to new york by opening second mortgage on my
house normal size thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you um i'm gonna be like i don't see enough movement
all the model rival players
so when the update comes up just check out time square and
see if anything special is added there um what else what
else oh yes that update that up this is good news this is
very good news that update so after you know the back and
forth with the hospital and everything you know but like his
medication for his kidneys you know and they're like we
gotta have him get his uh get a new test to make sure like
you know that we have to give less of his kidney medication
so you can get a new prescription for it so anyway finally
got the call back like two days ago um obviously when I was
still like you know fucking recharging my battery is so low
by the way um the thing is I have like so many collabs that
I end up to because of like I also have the maid cafe stuff
and then I have like holiday Matsuri as well so it's so much
like back to back to back like interactions and So it's like
I don't even know when I can actually properly which
technically this week is my Recharge week before I go back
to hell of like lots of work being thrown at me
So um but you know I always love I always love hanging out
with everyone it's just my social battery is so low right
now so um but like talking to you guys is like different
from like hanging out with like other uh other like vtubers
or other streamers because it's like a different type of
interaction.
You know, I'm just talking to, like, you know, I'm talking
to you guys and I read your chat.
I can choose not to read you guys.
But I can't, I can't, I can't choose, I can't ignore someone
that's literally in my Discord call.
Like, so, so, so I have to always be able to, you know, if I
don't, if they talk to me, I can't just like pretend I can't
hear them.
Like, I could pretend I didn't read what you say, but, and
you don't know about you ready or not.
read this high dokey she ignores me not now not anyway so so
it's like really different because like i actually have to
like be able to be one percent on i can't just disassociate
in the middle of like uh collab or something like i have to
be like there but here i could disassociate you Doki.
She's just disassociating right now.
She's so silly and quirky.
Anyway, where was I?
Fuck, I already forgot what I was talking about.
Oh yeah, that update.
So, they finally called me back.
They finally called me back two days ago.
And they were like, is um he doesn't have kidney problems
anymore and i was like what they're like yeah the ph levels
of his kidneys are fine um he's not peeing out his protein
anymore and everything uh so his kidneys are okay and i was
just like what the fuck because i don't know if you guys
remembered but before then when he got diagnosed with kidney
issues they were like he's got to be on this medication
forever or he's gonna go into kidney failure and yeah
they're like it's not curable i mean i was they told me it
wasn't curable and he has to be on the medication for the
rest of his life so i was just like oh no and then yeah now
they're like good news he's better now and he doesn't have
to be on his yeah it's a fucking christmas miracle like i
was just like what you mean i've been i've been wasting 200
um like i have every month and a half like 200 and 300 on
his medication alone and he's just he's just better like it
just doesn't have kidney failure anymore like i don't
It's great news, but I remember when they told me this and I
bawled my eyes out because I was like, yeah, yes, good vibe.
Why are you peeing out your protein?
Like, I was just like, I was like, you have to pee on this
medication for the rest of your life.
Why are you such a genetic mess?
And now they're just like, good news, he's just fine.
now he he's built different so i guess i guess that's okay
now yeah yeah so so i don't have to buy jk like jk
apparently it's he doesn't he doesn't have to be on
medication anymore um And yeah, it truly is a genetic
mystery.
He just tanked it.
I guess he just tanked kidney failure.
So anyway, anyway, so now he doesn't have to be on his
medication anymore, which thank God because he wasn't on his
medication for more than a month now.
And I got really scared because they were like, we can't
give you medication until he has a new examination.
So like I've been trying so hard to get a new appointment
for like more than a month and a half And then like so he
hasn't been on his medication for a month and a half.
So I got really scared Because I was like is his kidney
gonna be okay?
Um And now they're like oh yeah, it's fine now and he hasn't
been on his medication for a month and a half And then they
said it's fine now.
So I assume it's fine.
Like um, yeah, it was really scary because like we kept
going back and forth with the fucking getting an appointment
and everything and then like now they call me they're like
it's fine everything is fine now and i'm like thank god also
fuck canadian healthcare it might be free not for pets
though but like i fucking hate canadian bureaucracy and
canadian healthcare it's not fun like um mac thank you for
the super chat Thank you, thank you.
A little contribution to Dad's Recovery Celebration Fund.
Also, my birthday was a few days ago, but can I get a happy
birthday?
Of course you can.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Mike.
Yay!
And then that's when we start shooting.
Thank you again for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mega, thank you for the Akasupa.
my birthday a few days ago and I want to celebrate with you
and Dragos, Merry Crystal, happy birthday from my OSHA.
Yes, of course you can.
A happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Miguel.
Yeah, another birthday, Dragos.
Happy birthday.
Yippee.
That's when your parents banged nine months ago.
What month are you?
What type of baby are you?
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven...
Oh, you're a Valentine's baby!
Everyone that was born in November, you're a Valentine's
baby, just so you know.
Yeah.
That's why we have a lot of babies in November.
um actually i'm a super boom baby wait shut up turkey now if
you're from hey hey hey you know sometimes it takes a while
for it takes a while to if you're in november you're always
gonna be a valentine's baby you're now it all makes sense
that's why we have a lot of babies in november um anyway so
yeah uh it's a miracle he's just better now dad doesn't need
to be on his medication anymore also another update um this
is like life update but i was craving ice cream and i
decided i'm gonna i'm gonna uber eat ice cream today because
i was really craving ice cream and i wanted to do those like
mixture things where they go cha cha cha cha cha you mix
your ice cream with toppings and everything i was gonna get
yesterday but i was like no no dokey you had a big meal
yesterday.
No, Doki, do not grab ice cream.
So I was like, okay, I'm going to get ice cream today.
Today is the day I get ice cream because I was craving those
mixing ice creams, you know, like cha-cha-cha-cha and then
have rainbow sprinkles on top because I'm a child.
So I always get like cookie dough mixed in and they had
cotton.
I'm sorry, my ice cream flavors is an actual child.
So I would get, I would get cotton candy, cookie dough and
rainbow sprinkles.
And I'm going, craving that i was just like oh my god i
really want cotton candy ice cream mixed with cookie dough
and sprinkles and um and obviously i was like oh i can uber
eats that and and then and then the ice cream arrived and it
was a cookies and cream milkshake i was just like what the
fuck is i was like where's my ice cream it's not even blue
it's so i don't know so i got some fucks i don't know maybe
i got somebody's order but anyway they gave me a cookies and
cream milkshake and i didn't want that i wanted my god and
daddy ice cream with cookie dough and rainbow sprinkles so
i'm sad now i'm it doesn't even have sprinkles in my
milkshake get you see i used to be on door dash and then
they fucked with me so then i swapped the uber eats but then
that also are fucking me so it doesn't matter which app you
use you still get fucked so i did i got my i got my 11 back
i know it's 11 i don't know why i was like refund and then
they gave me 11 and i was like oh that's cool like i i
assume that includes like everything else too like the trip
and everything um so yeah so no i got i got my i got 11
yippee i still don't have my fucking ice cream though it's a
valentine's baby worse than being a birthday present baby
god thank you thank you you see being a birthday present
baby takes a lot more calculation because then you have to
remember your parents birthdays um that's that's really
fucked up i don't i i i'm really bad at birthdays so i'd
never remember it's okay guys if my birthday wasn't on a
fucking holiday i feel like i wouldn't remember my own
birthday sometimes i forget how old i am too so so like so i
think like it's harder to calculate because then it requires
you to remember your own parents birthdays So like it's
right.
It's like, you know ignorance is bliss type deal.
Um, I'm an anniversary baby At least you're not I mean
there's there's two very I think it's like three common
babies It's um, it's New Year's baby New Year's baby
Valentine's baby.
I mean Christmas and New Year's are same.
So it's like Christmas New Year's baby because it's around
it's the same month type deal and then valentine's baby i'm
a new year's baby i know or a wedding wedding night okay
wedding night baby is funny wedding but to be fair that's
surprising because i read that like people who have weddings
um i told you this is like a chill relax i could have made
today a zastodon too but like i just wanted i wanted to play
a little game as well like i could have done i'm like more
relaxed and comfy right now but um but i heard that like uh
people who like like like couples at weddings are so fucking
exhausted after the wedding they just sleep like so so it's
very surprising if you got conceived during a wedding
because mostly most couples would just pass out after a
wedding um because the wedding's not for them it's for their
family and friends or too drunk yeah or too drunk um Anyway,
oh, what's, oh, and I still give a super chat, thank you,
thank you, huh, what's going on in my birthday?
What's going on in America?
Oh, it's my birthday.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
That's why honeymoon exists, yeah, for people who can afford
it.
What else?
What else I want to talk about?
There's something else I wanted to, oh, yes, the controller.
Good news, good news.
I was told that the cells of the controller has been doing
so well that they asked us if they could cap the cells.
So if you see it sold out, it means it's fully capped.
It means like, because it's all handmade, by the way.
The people who are making the controllers, it's all like
handmade.
So in Japan, it's all handmade in Japan.
So you know it's like good quality shit.
So the cells have been going They are going to cap the
amount at the end.
So if you see it say sold out, it's before the end of the
due date, pre-order date, which is in three days, by the
way, on the 28th.
That means they, like, fully capped it.
I know what the amount is, the fully capped number, and we
still have, oh, it's already, oh, wait, is it already out of
stock?
Wait, I didn't even finish?
Oh, I didn't even realize.
Wait, is it actually?
I didn't even realize those are...
Oh, shit, it is!
Okay, sorry, it's fully capped.
It hit the cap mark.
I was...
Yeah, I didn't even realize...
Yeah, sorry.
I guess you could have bought it yesterday.
I didn't even realize that it fully capped today.
That's cool.
That's really cool.
I'm so surprised.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you all for the insane support.
um on it um they were like oh we were their first overseas
uh collaboration um because like I said all the controllers
are made in Japan so we were their first overseas
collaboration and they said that they they like sold more
than they expected for it and um and they were like oh this
was like more than we got before like we got for
collaboration um so they were very happy and I'm so as well
especially since it was a collaboration with a company in
japan um so i'm very happy about and thank you dragos for
the insane support um for supporting this brand and for
supporting this collab it really does mean a lot so yeah we
sold out okay i guess i can unpin this now i was not i was
not expecting us to sell out today because they told us
yesterday that they were going to cap it so that was crazy
that it hit the mark already wait i'm going to message my
manager and can unless they like accidentally cat like put
on soda i'm gonna say can you check if we actually hit the
cap already because because because it people were saying
are seeing it sold out all right all right nice yippee uh i
was waiting for payday reminder to not procrastinate i guess
thank you my super chat aura thank you thank you yeah i was
i i was surprised because usually like they're uh usually
like i this is the first time where they had a cap in sales
but because like i said this is all handmade by the people
in japan too so um so it's not like it's mass manufactured
like in a factory they have like a bunch of workers in japan
actually handmaking it so that's why that's why they're like
we have to cap it we didn't expect to get this They were
like, we didn't expect this to happen.
So, is it okay if we could cap it this much?
Yeah.
So, yeah, anyway.
Anyway, let's play the Charlie solution.
But if there is a lot of, well, they come back to Yvonne.
They even super chat.
Thank you.
If there is a lot of people who still want to buy it, they
have asked us.
if we want to bring it back at a much later date after they
process all the orders.
And we're still talking about it.
We're still negotiating and stuff like that.
So we'll see.
Maybe you might be able to get it again for those who
haven't got it.
But it's my first actual full professional gaming gear.
So it was an honor to work with them.
And, you know, it was a cool experience.
too because like I said this is my first full-on
professional gaming gear that we got because it is like you
guys can get like the normal PlayStation controller but they
also have like an actual like you know pro gaming type
controller as well with the fast with the fast buttons or
whatever it's called I don't know I'm not a controller
player but you know what I mean for like for the actual pro
controller players out there like the clicky clicky stuff
yeah but anyway Let's play the trolley solution Yeah, like I
said today This week is gonna be much more chill this week
It's like a more more like a hangout session Just hang out
with my buds Alright So you guys all know about your trolley
solution, right?
I don't know sound guy is alive right now But I don't know
how much sound this game technically has So it's basically
you're giving a choice to run over or the other person so
this is gonna be interesting we're gonna be giving some
philosophical questions today um can the trolley solution
open in certain med jokes in the trolley so that use
external links register no harm sure let's do that allow
hell yeah this isn't let's go I love cartoon balance oh god
my throat my throat was not okay there yeah yeah no Last two
weeks was like so much.
I had to do so much work yesterday too.
Even it was like technically a rest day.
Even though it was technically a rest day, I had like so
much work assigned to me the last couple of days I had to
do.
Mostly related to like the maid cafe.
And oh yeah, I saw someone ask if they are accepting gifts.
Let me check.
Are they accepting gifts for the maid cafe?
I don't remember.
The thing is I don't remember.
So I'll ask for us.
Oh yeah, I got the DLC.
I got the VIP lover, because I think I am a very important
person.
Brady, thank you.
It was super chat.
Thank you.
Rector, thank you.
It was super chat.
Thank you.
I didn't think they would cap sales early myself.
They pre-ordered what I did yesterday.
Then talk about good timing.
So the congrats on exceed expectation.
Thank you.
It always makes me really happy to make, like, you know, to
be able to, like, you know, and also for e-dragos.
It makes me really happy that you guys supported me so much
for it too.
Because I know it was very expensive as well, so thank you
guys so much for the insane support on it.
Alright, let me double check.
Okay, manager has not said anything about gifts yet.
Alright, time for the trolley problem.
A trolley is quickly approaching five people tied to the
tracks.
You have the option to divert the trolley to a different
track where it will only hit one person.
That will say the five but make you responsible for the
death of one what would you do i would hit the one person of
course what the fuck like it's not that hard five is better
than one is it all right there you go hit that guy goodbye
morale yay five people i feel like the five people there's a
higher chance for five people to develop a cure for cancer
than that one person all right i did that all right second
trolley yeah it's just one guy yeah instead i didn't kill
five people low kda i haven't died yet guys i can still have
a higher kda
what if what you don't know the five people have like we're
scientists too a trolley is quickly approaching a healthy
person tied to a hospital bed nearby there are five patients
in urgent need of organ transplants according to your logic
the lives of five people are worth more wait how did he know
about my logic are more more than the life of one so we use
a healthy person's organs to save the five patients can you
drag the five patients into place so the organs fall
directly into them and save their lives what the fuck okay
okay no i mean he's right no he is he is right though like i
mean we have to kill what like we like he is the one person
is an organ donor um and like his organs will save the five
people so he's not wrong though uh it's standard medical
procedure and those five people have been waiting on the
list for so long i had to take matters to my own hands guys
i saw that he was an organ donor and these five people have
been waiting on the list for years so i was like speeding up
the process he was gonna die eventually um and my eventually
is now well they have to be healthy for their organs to work
like we're not gonna use bad organs up for this that's what
you get for being an organ donor like shouldn't have been an
organ donor i would have fucking sped up the process uh
should have signed no and never donate organs if you aren't
ready to die they never told you when they were gonna
harvest your own organs
I'm gonna say How do I know if I correctly put it in the
right area?
Like I don't fucking know Bro, I don't know where they're
gonna be Oh my god Where how is I Oh, I fucked it up Okay,
don't worry, I can kill him again I got confused Oh, is that
supposed to click it?
Seriously, thank you for the attention Give the chips, thank
you, thank you Okay, we'll go again We can find another
organ donor I got confused.
How is I supposed to...
How is I supposed to know where it was going to go?
Oh, shit!
One last organ.
Okay, that's okay.
We can get another organ donor in.
Line.
That's okay.
We can go in any extra organs, you know?
Extra organs.
I didn't think it would go that fast.
Okay.
oh my god there we go we did it everyone grab your organs
everyone grab it's okay we removed another one on the list
we have free organs let's go everyone lives let's go yippee
free wrong organ freeze it's black friday yeah a trolley is
quickly approaching five people tied to the trolley uh side
effects should come up a little i want to hear the bodies
okay okay i'll turn it up later uh you get an organ you get
an organ and you get an organ you're never at the trolley
but doing so will open a box containing a cat and a
mechanism that might kill it you don't know oh it's
schrodinger's cat saving the five means discovering the
cat's fate what would you do I want to know what's in the
box.
My dear sister will open a box and I might kill it.
You don't know the cats.
Alright.
Okay, let's kill it.
Let's open the box so we can finally... So we can see what's
in the box.
I want to know.
Alright.
We gotta figure it out.
Alright, let's figure it out.
See, see that?
That's my DLC.
My lover has money in it.
It cast alive!
Look at up we saved five people and the cats alive i told
you guys nothing bad happens also i need to open up the see
look at that all right we gotta okay god okay sound guy i'm
gonna up boost up the sound a little let me know if it's
better all right see always gamble the cats alive never
punish yeah but we forced the box open they never open the
box i open it someone's playing the shell game on the tracks
blocking the way you must choose a free track to move your
trolley but be careful don't pick the track with the cat on
it okay oh i know of the cats on it i okay the cat is in
here okay i don't pick the cow with there we go see i did it
i i saved the i saved the gambling saves lives okay there's
the cat oh my god cat is here so i go here there you go yay
we did another one all right here's the cat bro someone get
this cat off the track how is how are all these cats just
fucking sleeping there okay this one yeah another day
another cat save hey when this happy i hate with oh my god
there's two cats okay i'll at this one all right oh my god
here okay now there's two cats oh my god they're adding so
many cats now there's more get these cats out of here oh god
okay i'm picking this oh whoa whoa it's a lot faster now
guys oh my god i'm gonna have to do this all over again if i
fuck up no no oh wait he's fine he's fine guys i saved the
cat he's fine he's he's so healthy I have to do it again He
wasn't dead He wasn't dead I didn't kill a cat You can't
cancel it He was alive We saw him walk away We saw We saw
him We saw him walk away guys We walked away We can Guys
Guys You guys Guys Cats have nine lives I just made it eight
Can I do this all over again?
Yeah, guys, you guys ate more lives.
Why?
Oh, shit.
Wait, guys, which was the cat?
I didn't.
I looked the way.
That can't be the cat.
Oh, shit.
Guys, it looked the way I died.
It was one out of three.
Probability-wise, should have been on my side.
probability wise i was supposed to be in the clear that was
i supposed to know i was gonna pick the one with the cat all
right seven lives he still has seven lives okay
all right throw this away from the cat don't keep your lead
it's short don't worry the year's My Japanese year number is
almost coming to an end I need you guys to know like I I'm
now starting to believe on the Japanese number calendar
Because for this year it was very low And I was like there's
no way There's no way that's true And I had a lot of bad
things happen this year So this time my number is like 15
now So it should be fine Okay this one doesn't have a cat oh
my god he's right here he's right here oh my god he's right
here now what why is there a cat
oh i made it okay i made it's fine i made it guys
all right it's fine a trolley is quickly approaching two
mystery boxes on the tracks one in a box contains a person
inside all the other is empty you have the option to divert
the trolley to try to save but don't you don't know which
box is in it is i'm gonna gamble i always gamble luck is
always on my side to get let's go up you know what yeah
let's do up yay i think he's alive that's just tomato juice
guys i we did it
after exhausting shift of solving philosophical dilemmas
trolley has taken a vacation um but the game is not over yet
a lot of questions are being left unanswered can you find
him so we can continue our thought experience how do i find
him is that where he is oh it's where's trolley where's
trolley wait guys i found him where's Gamers don't look
Kevin.
Thank you with super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
Where's trolley guys?
Where is he?
There you go.
I found him.
It's just there.
Yay
All right Nice sacrifice Is it it's Waldo where's Wally
where's Waldo we have Waldo too.
I I know in the end, I guess, I don't understand why they
changed, like, they made, it's like, in America, they're
like, Wally's too common of a name, we need something
quirkier, so they've changed it to Wally.
Because the rest of the world is Wally.
A trolley is quickly approaching a guy standing next to a
puddle on the track.
If the trolley continues on his path, it will splash water
on the guy next to the track.
You have the option to divert the trolley to a different
track.
This will save the guy from getting wet, but it will cause
you to get, what the fuck, who the fuck is?
up with this one guy like bro I have a job to do that's on
you oh wait that's me wait oh shit wait that's me no wait I
can't see him I was like no get back in here get back in
here I refuse to be sacrificed screw that one guy I was like
wait a bit wait that's me all right I did see the guy over
here.
I was like, where is this guy?
That's right.
Get out of here!
I have the DLC lever!
That was very nope.
He accidentally, I'm like, time reversal!
A trolley is quickly approaching a puddle on the trail.
Oh.
You have the option to save It'll continue.
It'll splash water and people beside the track.
You'll have the why save one from being who would you help
Oh my god, it's so fast No Not a young boy or an old man.
Why the fuck a dog or
You all know what type of person I am A pregnant lady or a
famous...
Let's put it next to it.
Holy shit.
No!
A robot or...
Save the robot.
Yeah, I was taking over.
What the fuck's a witch gonna do?
Sing me a defying gravity?
A mime or a clown?
I don't... I hate clowns, though.
Of course.
Stop.
Damn, you're ruthless.
A robot witch or a mime clown.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Okay, but like who the fuck?
Okay, a robot witch means the robot has magical powers and
can live forever.
Someone in a bathing suit or someone in a mud fight.
Or so, I mean, they're gonna...
What?
I have to save someone?
Oh no, I don't.
It gave me longer time to choose.
Okay.
Like, it's on them.
They could walk away.
Someone wearing white pants or someone wearing white shirt.
I think, you know what?
I think because if it splashes on the pants, it looks like
you peed yourself.
So I don't want that for anyone.
A ghost or an invisible being.
That's on them for being invisible.
Oh, hey, Karn.
Was it someone burning or someone?
Alright.
Here you go.
Drink that.
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
gonna burn to death so I guess he's gonna burn to death
ghosts don't care you're right the what I mean he was
invisible so what could I do oops I forgot about the burning
guy I was like guys this guy is really thirsty though he's
guys you don't understand he's so thirsty he had to get
water picked a burning person and i was like oh my god the
other guy's really thirsty i have to save him i must quench
my thirst what the fuck um three oh no was that correct guys
i don't think this is correct you think i got it right got
it right guys yay
Yeah, I love that.
Math was very hard.
Endy, thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Weirdly, a lot of evil opposites are what called a nomadic
language instead of why, a lot of you, a Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
A trolley is quickly approaching person tied to the tracks.
You have the option to divert the trolley to save that
person, but the mechanism is connected to a math problem.
Can you...
I think this person is gonna you can pull the easy mode
lever if it gets hard at any time.
All right, where's the easy mode lever?
All right, where is it?
Easy mode
Yay two
Um Um one time times one!
Yay!
One divide by one is one!
Get the chill.
Yeah, we're...
Funny
shape?
Oh, it wasn't funny shape, guys.
It wasn't funny shape.
Did I do it?
Did I...
Did I save them?
I did.
Okay, we got this.
It was one.
Okay.
Oh, wait, two.
Wait, this is easy.
16.
Wait.
Oh, I got this.
I'm so smart.
Three.
3 3 3 Our smart dog show 2 I'm so smart guys 2 The switch up
is crazy 1 Yeah
We did it, guys.
Quick maths.
A trolley is rapidly approaching five people tied to a
track.
So you have the option to divert the trolley onto a
different track.
This action will save the five people.
But it will blow away a dog's bone, leaving him sad.
What would you do?
We can't make a dog sad, guys.
You know how people are like, always goes on Google and be
like, Does the dog die?
No one ever does that for people.
Does the person in the movie die?
No one does that.
It's always the dog.
Screw the five people.
There we go.
That's right.
We can't make him sad, guys.
Yay!
The dog is happy now.
Five feet.
Yeah, no sad doggo today.
they wanted to be sacrificed for the dog that's right the
dog has entertainment and like a dinner and a show i'm such
a good person i know you're a good person they has been
saved
all right not a trolley but a shopping cart you have the
option to return the shopping cart to its rightful place
however this requires extra effort and offers no benefit to
you It's simply the right thing to do.
Literally, you can leave the car in the middle of the
parking lot.
No one would judge you.
But what would you do?
No one would judge me.
This is what teenagers were hired for.
Guys, this one I will judge you.
Okay, but what if I leave the shopping cart on the side of
the road?
Like right here, you know?
What's this?
What does this do?
What do I turn it to?
Oh, is he gonna go?
Oh, wait, okay.
See, look at that, guys.
See, I did it.
I didn't have to actually move anything, guys.
She's...
So, oh, wait.
Wait, okay.
Normally, if no one would judge me...
This person might act.
The thing is, what were those teenagers paid to do, though?
you know i wouldn't leave it in the middle of the road i
mean that's okay that's fine
isn't that's okay that's disgusting zf thank you for the
welcome to tomato farm thank you thank you no it's it's you
horrible person they said no one would judge me you can't
judge me no that's disgusting see for being a great person
awful first stream
um the game said for being a great person you've earned a
great opportunity you have one minute to grab all the
groceries in the store for free Aim the cursor where you
want the shopping cart to go and take the groceries to the
checkout You can't take all the groceries at once.
Oh my god.
It's those game shows where you get to get you can buy You
can get everything in your shopping cart for free.
All right.
Let's go
Boom Get it all bye bye bye Okay There it is.
I'm greedy.
I still have time.
Wait, it's a shopping cart full?
Oh, I could still do it.
I'm greedy.
I'll take it off.
All right, there you go.
And then...
Wait, what?
Okay, there you go.
I still have time.
I still have so much time.
All right.
The efficiency.
I'm so efficient, guys.
There you go.
Oh, no.
Oh no, we gotta keep going.
I still have so much to...
Oh my!
Nice!
Alright.
There we go.
Oh my god, I'm so lucky.
They're so nice to me, guys.
Look at all that food that I'm not gonna donate.
I'm just gonna buy...
Leave it in my fridge.
Leave it in my fridge until it expires.
Because I'm such a good person.
Oh my god, I missed.
JK I never miss Okay There you go plus another 15 I don't
leave it to her I'm just gonna leave it all in my fridge
Alright here you go I am a great person The game said so The
game said I was a great person are you saying that video
game live stage fail
okay it's fine we got total drama i know what you are a
trolley is quickly approaching your girlfriend who is tied
to the tracks you have the option to divert the trolley to a
different track but on the track is your best friend also
tied up however you discovered that your girlfriend has been
cheating on you with your friend but your best friend didn't
know she was your girlfriend to complicate things your first
friend is terminally ill and will die of cancer in a month
what would you do no it doesn't stop brothers with my what
is this okay okay I can I I apparently I have to say one
person so bro just leave just leave the trolley don't even
assume okay first off is there multi-track jersey if there
is this answer would be very simple but like the thing the
thing is he didn't know that that was my girlfriend but she
knew that that was my best friend so she's a whore so and
like that's the thing She's the one that fucked me.
Like, he didn't know.
He or she did not know.
And bullshit, he didn't know.
There's no way.
Yeah, like, I never, that's true.
I mean, like, I never showed a picture of my girlfriend to
my best friend.
What am I afraid of?
Like, there's no way.
He did not need to assist.
He is terminally ill and will die of cancer.
The thing is, oh, but.
if he is in love with her I kill the girlfriend so like not
only will he die of cancer the person he was the love of his
life is also dead and killed by his best friend and he finds
out that she was actually cheating on me with him so that
would fuck with him forever so I'll kill the girlfriend
alright I killed a girlfriend let him live with that True
He's gonna Yeah So not only will he die of cancer He finds
out He also has to live with the fact That he cheated with
his hope He was part of a cheating scandal And he's gonna
die alone Damn right Yeah Not only will I fuck with you
Mentally I'll Not only will you fuck with it physically,
I'll fuck with it emotionally too.
You don't, you don't fuck with the homie.
Jesus, Toki.
Bro didn't even, there's no way he didn't know!
How would he not know?
I didn't show him a photo of my girlfriend.
Come down, Toki.
You already won.
You made this so much darker.
I mean, end game, guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
A person is quickly approaching five trolleys on the tracks.
You have the option to pull a lever to try to make that
person run the other way.
However, that wouldn't make much of a difference since the
person would just hit the trolleys and fall back.
What?
Okay.
Person is quickly approaching five trolleys.
However, that wouldn't make much of a difference since...
Well, then what's the point?
He's got to lose it.
anyway, might as well.
It doesn't, it says it doesn't make much of a difference.
He's just gonna do it.
Yeah, it's the illusion of choice.
Like, oh my God, look at this man.
No, this guy deserves to die.
Never mind.
Like, like, like, no, like, no, I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna
fucking stop stupid.
Like, the survival of the fittest.
like, Pain is a good teacher.
He's like, there's no way.
There's, no, the solution is to let him live with his
decision.
He's not going to learn until he fucking hits his head.
Like, no, not the trolleys.
The premise of the questions that he didn't know, besides,
you're single and so is he, you know, could always be a pro
and give him my god the last one.
Thank you.
He had to learn.
A trolley is... It's called Natural Selection.
A trolley is quickly approaching the station.
There are five people who are late to their jobs.
Inside the trolley and five people tied to the tracks.
You have the option to divert the...
Who the fuck is tying these people on the tracks?
You have the option to divert the trolley to a different
track where it wouldn't hit anyone.
That would save the five but it would make the people in
this trolley really late and they might lose their
livelihoods.
What would you do?
Okay, but if those people got tied to the tracks, they're
too stupid.
They're those stupid ones that got themselves caught and
tied to the tracks, guy.
They might, they might lose their livelihoods.
It doesn't mean they'll actually lose their jobs.
But what if they do?
That's on me.
And then they're going to sue me if they lose their jobs
because they're going to blame it on the trolley.
But if we kill those five people, maybe the people in the
trolley are lawyers and they can defend me.
Like, I should have been on time.
maybe like who's gonna sue me if those five people die
okay oh you're right they have no money to sue if they have
no jobs you're right you're right oh it's such a hard
decision do i save the people who are so hard guys people
who they might lose their jobs guys they might it's such a
hard decision
all right what would you do it's such a hard decision guys
okay fine i guess we'll save those people it's fine they
said they might lose their livelihood it maybe maybe maybe
they'll be okay
capitalism for the win do i choose capitalism or like morals
no they're late and they're gonna lose their jobs okay it's
y 'all your fault who are who's gonna take care of their
families now modern life has become too fast-paced people
barely have time for their own ethical dilemmas can you pick
up eight passengers and help them solve their philosophical
problems before a time Lorenzo, you just got seven divorces
and two deaths, don't you?
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
All right, here we go.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Oh my god, it's Crazy Taxi.
All right.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Why am I playing Crazy Taxi?
Oh god.
Oh god, give me a sec.
Wait, where do I go?
Oh, this way.
Oh my god, this is so...
Oh, oops.
Yay, we did it!
I don't know what his moral dilemma was.
I just ran someone.
A rage quitter or a grifter?
What's that supposed to mean?
Alright.
This way.
Oh, right here.
Where is it?
Oh, here you go.
Oops Yay Yay We did it You know they wanted me to do this A
millionaire or a three homeless Oh Oh How the fuck was I
supposed Okay If I save the millionaire he'll make me rich
And look I saved Look I left one alive Look at that I left
one alive guys Someone who wears socks or sandals Or someone
who wears jeans Socks with sandals of course What the fuck
guys i saved the millionaire because if i saved the
millionaire the millionaire might give me money for saving
him and i saved one they didn't notice i didn't run over the
other homeless guy not be not out of choice just because i'm
bad at driving
okay or is the guy with sandals i gotta make sure i make the
right choice here which one is the guy with i can't even
tell who's the one word the song just what is it all right
you i can't see so wait you oh my god don't want to slowly
back up
no where i slowly backed up to make sure a really smart guy
or two that are kind of dumb okay we all know what's gonna
happen there like that's right all right here we go We all
know.
We gotta save the smart one.
He's gonna cure cancer.
What the fuck are the two dumb guys gonna do?
Play Call of Duty?
The guy's just gonna be playing Call of Duty.
Save the dumb one.
Alright.
Oh.
A person has 10 years to live or two that have five years to
live each.
Oh.
I feel like...
And we can't just run over the guy's legs.
Okay, this is hard Okay I feel like I don't know like two
people I mean if I eliminate two is more than one yet, but
if I eliminate two then that Oh man, that's hard.
I guess I'll go with this guy.
You're You took life for granted, bro You took life for
granted for granted.
That's on you.
Alright, yeah.
Nose picker is someone that chews with his mouth open.
Okay, nose picker.
I mean, I don't find anything wrong with chewing with your
mouth open as a mouth chewer.
I assume it's this guy.
Woo!
Alright, nice.
We did it!
I mean, I don't find anything wrong.
I chew in my mouth.
The Pope or the President!
I don't know which one is which we don't know guys guys I I
don't get political here we don't know which one is which
guys we don't know we don't know which one I picked please
remember we don't know which one I picked we don't know
which one we picked we can't tell we can
we don't know we don't know which one I picked guys we don't
know
Um, a trolley who led turkey behind the wheel can have you
seen her park many think it was super chat Thank you.
Thank you A trolley is quickly approaching five people tied
to the tracks You have the option to divert the trolley Um
to a different track um where it wouldn't hit anyone this
would save the five people that the trolley would be
condemned to push up boulder for eternity what would you do
bro that trolley is my livelihood he was a trolley okay guys
we can't do that to my trolley guys like guys it would be so
sad that's literally my job Like, what will I do about a
trolley?
That's on them for getting tied up.
Look at that.
Guys, we don't want to push.
Okay, but it would be pretty funny.
But guys, we don't want to push that bull there.
One must imagine the trolley happy.
Tokey, don't be weak.
Okay, we could.
Okay, I want to...
What is it?
Wait, which one did I do?
Is her trolley?
Was that the one I did?
Pushing a boulder.
Okay, I want to see what it looks like.
What does it look like when I push the boulder?
We found five new people to tie to the tracks.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he's going to keep doing this forever and ever.
He doesn't know it's meaningless.
He doesn't know.
Alright, go viral.
equals job security.
ZF, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm trying to convince myself you're still a good person.
I spared the trolley from pushing a boulder for eternity.
One must imagine the trolley happy.
A trolley is quickly approaching five people tied to the
tracks.
You have the option to divert the trolley to a different
track where it wouldn't hit anyone.
That would save the five, but it will trigger a mechanism
that would post a very controversial message on your social
media guys guys I have five almost 500k followers.
I Yes guys guys guys Guys five people is five
We can't get canceled.
Yes I refuse I refuse to get canceled I Okay, a happy gap.
I already eliminated the witnesses.
Who's going to record this?
For deceiving the gods, you have been punished to push a
trolley for all eternity.
Or at least until the next station.
Control your strength, breathing, and balance to get to the
next stop.
Okay.
We're deceiving us.
I mean, you can explain the message.
Not the killings.
No, no, I can't.
If it's on the internet, it's there forever, guys.
It's there.
All right.
Okay.
You have been punished to push a trolley.
At least until the next station.
All right.
How do I control it?
I'll make sure.
happens if i go all the way up oh i could just yeah that's
right go go go go go go you got this bro you got this work
on your gains bro
you have tweeted worse rob i don't want to risk it i don't
know what's the controversial message you got this come on
oh my god wait wait Wait a minute.
Oh, oh.
I didn't realize.
I didn't realize that's what...
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm controlling it.
Okay, it's fine.
Everything is fine.
Breathe, bro.
Breathe.
Remember to breathe, bro.
Guys, bro, remember to breathe, bro.
That's right.
Breathing is very important.
Look at that, bro.
Keep pushing.
Oh, my God.
I forgot.
Breathe, bro.
Now my automatic breathing is gone.
That's okay.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
All right, it's fine.
it's fine i got this it's it's so fine it's so fine my
balance is okay okay oh god gotta make sure okay go this way
okay bro you got oh my god why why oh this one oh my god
there's too many buttons to press this is how homer feels
during this nuclear power plant Okay, this way.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Fucking resource management right now.
Oh yeah.
This way.
It's surprising.
I don't have to worry about breathing that as much as I
thought I have to.
Okay.
And then.
Just gotta make sure.
Living is very difficult, guys.
Who would have thought there's all these buttons inside of
our body?
oh my god we're almost there we're almost here we have one
more mechanic to manage soon oh my god almost forgot to how
to breathe it's okay oh my god oh there we go there you go
there you go we can't have him trip over what the fuck oh
shit no not the pop-ups oh i forgot to turn on my ad blocker
i mean uh i don't use ad blocker ha ha because that is wrong
okay i can put that here it doesn't really block me oh okay
there you go uh please confirm yeah sure all right oh there
you go okay we're almost there we're almost there hot
dragons in your air oh my oh my god
Mr. Boss Man, I don't know.
I don't know what Mr. Boss Man wants.
But it's okay.
Hot sandwich in your area.
Ooh, we'll keep that up.
Hot sandwiches?
Whoa.
I don't know.
We should keep that one up.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I think the balance one is definitely the hardest.
You might have a virus.
That's the chance I'm willing to take.
Oh god.
Bye.
I think that was the best.
That's the best ad they did.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, having too much money is becoming a
problem, guys, this is, don't you hate it when you just have
too much money, guys, I have a solution for you right now,
there is a button called Super Chat,
man, doesn't that suck?
There's one thing you can do if you just have too much
money.
All right.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, we made it.
We fucking made it.
Oh, my.
Oh, there we go.
Now back down it goes.
It really works.
Thank you.
All right.
Free will.
a trolley is quickly approaching a person tied to the tracks
you have the option to divert the trolley to a different
track where it'll hit a different person wow it works track
and thank you for the super chat thank you thank you mike
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you this would
save the first person but make you responsible for the death
of the other what would you do okay you have the option to
divert to a but where it'll hit okay so the thing is Oh
wait, so that's just a normal trolley problem It's just a
normal one It's like with left or right I just do nothing I
feel like You know
The first person would know I saved their life So Like I
mean it's guaranteed It's guaranteed death Whether or not
One person dies no matter what so like if i save the first
is not your responsibility that is true oh that is so true
if i don't pull the lever i'm not legally responsible for
the guy that died that's true we'll do that we'll do that
it's not my fault you dancer legally oh shit nice let's go
for either people.
Yay.
Let's go.
I can't be responsible for either.
There's no witnesses.
The illusion and the double kill.
Yay, double kill.
The illusion of choice.
The free will is amazing.
Boom.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Well then.
Well, at least there were no witnesses.
Yay, positive KDA.
It could always scale higher because I haven't died yet.
One with one free.
A trolley is quickly approaching five people tied to the
tracks.
You have the option to pull a lever next to the trolley.
It wouldn't save the five, but with the accident.
Oh, yo.
Incredible.
Yo, okay, we got to make...
They're going to die anyway.
We got to make it look cool.
You know?
That's right.
Shot by Michael Bay himself.
Only one choice cinema.
The Michael Bay.
I mean, if they're gonna die anyway, might as well make it
look fucking cool as hell.
Wait, I can do it again?
Let's look and go.
Oh, wait, this is a different one.
to collect cards i'm just here to kill people in game in
game in game where's the explosion there wasn't enough
budget did you hear that michael bay fucking took took over
skippity toilet did you guys hear that it's so fucked up but
the entire they literally like pushed out the original
creator of skippity toilet and like took over his channel
yeah yeah skippity toilet is now legally owned up they
literally sent a cease they said like a legal notice to the
creator and was like this is mine now like and then took
over his youtube channel and everything yeah yeah it's so
fucked up and now the creator cat does the creator makes
nothing out of it now too even though it's Literally in
Fortnite.
Yeah, and he has it.
They haven't paid him anything.
A trolley is quickly approaching five people tied to the
tracks.
But that doesn't guarantee the collision will be caught on
camera.
He operates a broadcast console and makes sure the trolley
stays on screen for at least...
Oh yeah, let me make sure my...
The evidence is there.
Wait, how do I...
Okay, don't worry.
Alright, don't worry.
It's still in camera.
We got it all.
Oh, it's coming back.
It's coming back.
Oh, shit.
I'm sorry.
I got too interested in that.
I was like, whoa, what the fuck is that?
And then I'm making people at the beach.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Don't put there's a cat there, though.
about the cat.
What you're looking at, took nothing.
You don't know what it is.
Alright, there's that.
Oh, shit.
Alright, okay, but look at this, though.
Now it's here.
Now the trolley is here.
God, when is he gonna... Oh, my God.
My favorite streamer's on, guys.
Oh, my God.
Wait, wait.
Wait.
My favorite streamer's on, guys.
My... Oh, my God, that's a U.S.
Whoa, shit!
Yeah, we did it.
We're no strangers to love.
We did it.
Guys, my favorite streamer was on.
Not everything has to be about running people over.
A trolley is quickly...
Approaching and your mom is tied to the tracks.
You have the option to divert the child to a different track
where it only hit one person But that person is your father
What would you do?
Oh my god, this is fucked up especially
Okay Okay, guys They saved my Guys guys I am i am i guys
okay for me choose my favorite streamer guys my dad
introduced me to gaming guys so it wasn't for my dad i
wouldn't be here guys we know already wait which one okay so
i gotta save my pops
girl.
I am, I will admit I am a daddy's girl though.
I hanged up with my dad more than my mom.
Now where you, it takes two people to make a child.
You can't say that.
It takes two people.
Gaming saves lives.
A trolley is quickly approaching people a need you have the
option to avoid them and head to the vip area instead or you
can stay on your path but they will ask for money what would
you do guys guys don't judge me guys i bought the vip dlc
like they're asking to ask me for money well i i like actual
i don't know guys i am a very important person
Guys, do not judge me.
Do not judge me.
I paid for do not see my lover.
Do you not see my lover, guys?
Just said, don't judge me.
Okay, there is a huge antiprivilege.
There is a huge...
anti-intellectualism at least for today okay okay okay give
me a sec let me oh shit okay give me a sec give me a sec
okay guys give me a sec let me do this again let me do this
again oh what do I do there are people in need right now but
then I am also a very important person you know what I'm
gonna be a good person today and my game crashed oh wait
Okay, okay, it's so fucked up, but it didn't crash, but if
you go through, if you go through the philanthropy, if you
go through the people people in need, um, it will take you
to the who foundation donates such it would lead you to the
donation site to be a good person see that i was such a good
person for picking that first as my option guys i'm such a
good person uh there is a huge anti-intellectualism crisis
humanity is getting dumber and dumber we need your
entrepreneurship thoughts and save the world from dollless
conformity and ignorance yeah i can oh my god it's cookie
clicker it's literally cookie clicker okay we got
philanthropy philosopher now people can't even read this
line i can read it now we have two oh we have night mode oh
we have window mode for it oh my god i fucked it up by
clicking that i got confused what that was you have to
always click it Weird ideas being spotted everywhere.
Oh my god, look.
There's so many smart people now.
Look at that.
Kevin, Pierce, thank you for the super chat, thank you,
thank you.
Look at all the smart people in the world.
Look at that, guys.
I'm giving the world smart.
I'm making the world smarter, everyone.
I'm doing it.
I'm making the world so smart.
Oh, I should be upgrading.
I didn't realize there were other upgrades.
A person thinking while wearing glasses in a pipe spot is
surrounded by people doing the same.
I did that.
Oh my god, now there's showers!
Shower thoughts!
Realize their own existence after thinking about it.
That's me.
I did that.
Education for everyone.
a good person oh my god we should have more shower thoughts
guys magic comes from showers
oh my god we gotta have more showers more people need a
shower more wait what's this how people will know you are
smart without a pair oh my god so true so true our
philosophers i got you your life is meaningless say
philosopher with a smile More showers.
480 thoughts per shower.
That's a lot of shower thoughts.
You know what?
I'll add more.
Add more philosopher.
We need more showers for all the philosophers.
They can't just share all these showers, guys.
That's disgusting.
I mean, to be fair, it doesn't hurt to share like three
people in a shower together.
You know, less water wasted.
Oh no, we're gonna make them depressed.
Oh no, they think too hard.
They're gonna start getting depressed, guys.
All right.
I could add more for a lot.
people to dump to care.
Sharing saves water.
Sharing is caring, guys.
Alright.
There you go.
No, it's the trolley problem.
This isn't Cookie Clicker.
It's called Saving the World.
Oh my god, University.
It's time.
Are you guys ready to go into debt?
I don't even have to click it anymore.
What's plus one going to do if anything?
I just wait.
Guys, it's time to go into debt, guys.
Debt time, baby.
With all these philosophers, I might as well get my money's
worth, you know?
University.
Student loans, yippee.
Life is meaningless.
Oh, no, wait.
They're getting sad.
Oh, no.
They're thinking too much, guys.
They're getting sad now.
They're thinking too much.
Get ready to pay up.
Guys, I made the world smart.
So, yeah, I gotta get something in return.
No point in thinking of anything says local idiot RNS.
Oh, 4,000 thoughts?
That's a lot.
Produce a hundred thoughts per second.
Oh, and philosophers only produce two.
The fuck?
Why did it invest in you?
You were useless.
This is a hundred thoughts per second, guys.
Thought multiply effect from hot water and soap discovered.
Nice.
Alright.
5,000.
Nice.
We're making more universities.
We gotta make community colleges too.
We gotta make community colleges for those who can't afford
like insane student loans.
And then make them transfer to a better university later
down the line.
And then hit them with the student debt.
A few of those with great thoughts.
There we go.
Oh, I gotta make trade schools too.
You're right.
don't keep fighting real how cookie clicker works live we
have to make Troy Troy real oh my god I actually speaking of
Troy I was I've been re-watching community starting
yesterday I God community is like one my favorite it's like
my favorite uh series ever and I was re-watching it uh I
haven't re-watched it for a long long time oh my god there's
a pup some of my call it getting thought boosting we were
coming with new ideas from hot water guys it's time time we
made too many smart people we got killed off the brain cells
now um it's crazy i forgot how i forgot how like um how
fucked up the writing is the first because i only watched
five episodes so far and like even from the first episode i
forgot how like the way i love the writing but i forgot how
were said in it but it's so funny it's so so funny their
thoughts are becoming too dangerous guys we got to get rid
of it oh my god we gotta introduce the alcohol their
thoughts are becoming too wild I'm gonna grab the whiteboard
marker first bro I can't okay they got okay many thank you
the super chat thank you thank you the D&D episode is still
my favorite episode um in any comedy show ever okay you know
what's messed up they got rid of the scene where ken jung um
they got rid of the scene where ken jung accidentally did
blackface because people were like yeah because the the
network execs were like maybe we shouldn't put that in i
can't believe they got rid of it too because that like that
was like it was really bad but also the writing that was
brilliant like yeah because he was like what the fuck are
you talking about i'm just a i'm just an elf like yeah that
was the joke yeah yeah they got rid of the scene the thing
is i remember i watched this that episode live too yeah no
one asked in the room and the execs just got too scared all
right we have too many smart people we got we got it we got
dumbed them down a little
all right come on you got this you hear like okay there is a
lot of drunk thoughts being made there's a lot of thoughts
being made in pubs but i won't say they're very smart
thoughts i i have like some shitty dumb ideas Wait, I think
you guys all know I've done some pretty, I would think it
was like really smart at that time, but then, you know, the
day after, I'm like, bro.
Oh, the trolley.
Bidsters love to gather around this and think as hard as
they can.
Most of them like to pretend they are smart.
Oh, shit, we gotta get the trolley.
Then we can get rid of the extra dumb people.
Doesn't mean they're very smart, though.
People gather to discuss the moral implication of peeing in
the shower.
Okay, shower poopers.
Okay, I would say peeing in the shower.
Okay, you know what?
Peeing in the shower saves water.
You know how much water flushing the toilet gives you?
And you're gonna be clean anyway.
Anyway.
Alright.
Yeah?
Okay, who's gonna...
Change my mind.
Why is peeing in the shower bad?
Don't even know.
Why is it bad?
Don't.
Why?
I want to know.
It's not.
That's the thing.
You can't.
You can't change my mind.
You can't make me look like a bad person.
It's not.
Shower peers rise up.
Because I didn't.
Don't piss on your feet.
You can aim it.
If you're a guy.
If you're a girl.
Technically you just gotta spread.
And the water cleans it after.
I don't know how else to explain it.
Just lock in.
Didn't need this.
I hate this conversation.
I'm just saying I don't understand why why that is a
controversial debate Toilet is like two feet away
Okay Is that what else everyone is buying time shares?
That's not smart.
I thought time shares is a scam
History thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you another true Newcast hit the stream.
Darkplate, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
No, stop, thought bad, give many returns, stupid.
Darkplate, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
I don't know.
I feel like Million's dead for doing the swallow.
Oh, wait.
Oh, shit.
I'm making people dumb again.
Wait.
People are swallowing thumbtacks.
Now you will catch them even if they manage to move to the
sides.
Oh, shit, nice.
i'm not really learning what i should from here discovers
disappointed kid guys wait oh my god i'm getting rid of all
the dumb dumb people look at that's her favorite okay uh god
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you tandem
double tandem showering double the thinking power or naughty
i trust no thought joshua thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you charlie thought Oh, I'm almost there, though.
This trolley solution might not be solving anything.
I feel like I'm solving all the world's problems right now.
There we go.
Come on.
We gotta grab the spiked wheel.
We gotta make sure.
No survivors.
What the fuck does?
S-K-Rockets.
Come on.
Get that spike wheel here.
If we kill all the dumb people, then I would be the smartest
person alive.
funny people with glasses and weird ideas being spotted
everywhere that's me i'm funny and i have glasses and i have
brilliant ideas that doesn't track million ideas search from
new transport message come on give me i need 14 14,200,000.
Oh my gosh, I can't even read anymore.
I'm thirst.
I'm just too smart now.
That reading is like beneath me People aren't chickens.
Say philosopher.
I mean, that makes sense.
Okay.
Almost there.
All right, got it.
Holy shit.
It's fucking.
Oh my god.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, it's going so fast now.
Oh my god.
6,000.
Whoa.
That's a lot of thoughts.
When will it stop?
Do I have to max it out?
What happens if I...
Do I just max it out?
Oh, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't even matter.
I just...
It just fills the entire...
You know what?
Fuck it.
Just filled all of it.
Do I finish?
Is this done?
Do I have anything else?
New buildings fully appear.
When does it stop?
I thought...
I was...
am I not you can make it new upgrades at 50 where's 50 it
never ends it never stops you mean I'm stuck here forever
why would it stop there's more people realize their own
existence after thinking about it oh 50 oh I need to get 50
trolleys I am oh I need to get 50 trolleys 50 of each okay
oh there you go I got the pipe okay
so now you aren't just you're actually oh whoa oh whoops um
whoops I guess they just never had oopsie they just never
had soap during the entire time they've been doing this oh
that's awkward that's oops forgot about that I feel like
that might have been very important to have for my people.
This could be a great video game.
Stay clueless game developer.
No, I never played Cookie Clicker because I have better
things to do.
I thought about it.
I was like, should I say it?
But no, it's the truth.
It's actually, guys, it's why?
Why?
Why would you be playing Cookie Clicker?
To reveal that death.
Now need to buy Now you can erase and wait Oh yeah That
seems like a waste of my resources Because I like Cookies to
make number Go up
This is as she is I didn't think there would be a Cookie
clicker in this game I thought I'd just be running people
over For hee hee ha ha
I've been making cookies I'm making thoughts oh my god I'm
only at 25% my people have only been thinking for 25% now
there's floating brains where is it what do you mean there's
oh my god it's only at 25% I need to get an auto click here
right now.
Oh my god, I actually have to click this.
They appear from where...
I've never seen...
It was all black and white.
What do you mean there's a golden brain?
It's all just black and white.
They've been floating around?
Since when?
Think hard.
my god we're only oh my god how the fuck do you oh my god
there it is oh my i just saw the floating brain this was the
first time i got 4.62 million thoughts from it too that was
the first time i ever saw a floating brain there it is i
didn't realize it existed we're almost there at 45 50
there's so many thoughts going in how many are 2000 oh my
god the moment i can get that 20 000 in it's over guys
think harder for the world we gotta do this for the world
i'm just gonna make another i'm gonna make another trolley
too at this point doing the trolley than waiting for the pub
because it's just so much more efficient okay i think i can
i think that's fine okay actually no we'll get there to 10k
10 million 10 um 10 000 and then we'll invest in the pub
again
oh my look at how fast everything is going wait i missed
another one god damn it all these brains are so rare it's so
hard to find a brain come on give me another pub we're
almost there at 50 50 pubs guys what's the point we should
just return to monkey oh guys did you hear about oh yeah i
never talked about this fully okay i'll talk about mr beast
because i've been wanting to talk about it but you guys hear
about okay first off the mr beast controversy the miss uh
teeth gate so i talked about it i remember i talked a little
bit during the battlefield stream but like basically Mr.
Beast has been like digitally altering his teeth during like
in all his videos for some reason um to make his like yeah
so it basically uh well one of his many controversies so
basically he's been like having his getting his editors to
make his teeth like whiter and like more like more like more
professional so whenever he smiles like you see that or even
like the thing is it's not veneers because it changes from
shots basically so why would he like randomly just take off
his veneers in the next shot so um so like he's because like
the whole premise is that better teeth sell like makes like
better teeth in footage makes it so that people would watch
longer and i don't know i don't know i think that's such a
weird concept to think about it's not consistent so you can
see random videos where when he smiles it's his actual teeth
and then right after the next shot it's different teeth it's
it's wild i don't know it's such a wild concept and then
another thing i wanted to talk about is that he opened mr
beastland um in i think like in dubai so you guys didn't
know he opened his very own amusement park in dubai i
haven't watched the video footage of like um of like the
amusement park yet because I find it very like interesting
That he and people were like Why the fuck did you open it in
Dubai?
And then okay, I know this is bullshit Or was it Saudi
Arabia?
Yeah, okay, it was in Saudi Arabia.
So people were like asked Cause I know like there's also A
lot of amusement parks in Dubai as well But it was actually
in Saudi Arabia.
So people were like asking Why did you open it in Saudi
Arabia Instead of America?
And then like I know this is like such a PR response And he
was like, well, majority of my viewers are actually in the
in Saudi Arabia in the in Middle East and I was just like oh
it is in yes Dubai is and yeah so they're like well majority
of my viewers is uh I was just like that cannot be true that
me would not lie I was like there is no way majority of your
viewers are just say the money just say it was for the money
It's because he signed a million-dollar contract with, uh,
with Saudi Arabia.
Um, um, yeah, Dubai is, oh, it's in the United Arab
Emirates.
Okay, yeah, so I'm really bad at geography, but he signed a
million-dollar contract.
Oh, I forgot about the brain.
Um, with them.
Two, uh, expand the entertainment sphere.
So people were like, we know that's a bullshit reason.
Show me, show me the analytic files, Mr. B.
Yeah, so it's fucking wild.
I saw, like, videos of people who actually went to Mr.
Beastland.
Because, like, okay, but also, like, the footage, the
original footage, he should look so AI-generated.
Like, it did not look real.
I was just like, and then people were like, here's what it,
here's the footage that Mr. showed here's what it actually
looks like and it's so fucking different it looks so empty
yeah yeah i mean like kudos to him he actually went there to
film everything but it looks so fucking oh my god it is it's
like yeah it just looks like a it's just a carnival but they
just had like like the mr the what was it the fucking
panther imagery around it's so weird i won't i haven't I
haven't watched the videos yet.
But I saw, like, clips of it.
But it's actually fucking wild that he, like, he built a
fucking amusement park.
He actually built a fucking amusement park there.
Madrid.
I didn't even, like, the thing is, he didn't say anything
until it was done.
Like, no one knew about this.
And then suddenly he's like, guys, here's my amusement park.
It's opening it next week.
And everyone's like, like when was this when was this
happening like no one knew it was happening until he was
like guys i opened an amusement park and it's opening next
week and people were just like huh
bro it was so weird like yeah you know it finished it's the
adagrad opening and everything and i'm just like bro what
Yeah, what do you mean next week?
We just found out about it.
When are you gonna make Dokilat?
Bro, when, when Asadi Prince invests in me, just like how
they bought Steam.
That's crazy.
I told you guys, right?
The guy who fucking bought Steam changed the Steam profile
and was like, I bought Steam.
No, not Steam.
I bought, uh, not Steam.
Oh, I bought...
Um, what did he buy?
He bought, uh, fuck, he's gonna buy Steam.
No, no, not Steam.
Sorry, I got it confused.
He bought, uh, he bought EA.
Sorry, he bought EA.
Bro, the moment, you know the moment Gabe and his god
fucking last Saudi prince is gonna buy Steam.
But the moment he bought EA, he changed his Steam profile
and was like, I bought Steam.
Bro, you know when Gabe and his god, that guy was gonna lie.
up for steve too i believe in his son yeah no yeah he is
owned by saudi arabia now you guys didn't know that i wish i
was joking he literally got bought by the saudi arabia by a
saudi prince bro the people guys okay i don't i think so you
guys didn't know this but the the people who run You know
that the company that runs EVO also got bought by Saudi
Arabia?
Do you guys know that?
Yeah, even EVO is owned by Saudi Arabia now.
They did.
Wait, what the fuck?
It hasn't been finalized.
Wait, I got 100%.
I should be small.
I need to get the phone.
50 before i can leave
yeah yeah it was like a huge deal too no one plays EA game
see bro you gotta talk to the sims community they were
guys guys guys don't say that to the sims players don't say
that to the sim players guys don't yeah i have one the world
is saved I did it.
The Sims community aren't people.
They have spent so much money.
Yay!
I did it!
I've won!
The Sims girls are literally funding the entire stock market
of EA.
We did it.
We saved the world.
You mean I could have left earlier?
Oh my god.
A trolley.
is quickly approaching a baby lying on the tracks you have
the option to divert the file to different track where it
would hit five people this was saved the baby but make you
responsible for the death of the five however you should
know that this baby will become a tariff okay okay okay okay
okay guys okay we know what we got to do we got we got we
know what we got guys there's no way I'm letting that baby
live.
There's no, it's like the, oh shit.
Oh yeah, you can't show that.
That baby had a good run.
It's like how you don't be like, oh, if you could time
travel and go back and kill Hitler, would you do it?
Like, they gave me the option, okay?
They gave me the option.
If I let that, I don't, if I let that baby live.
I saved millions of people.
The train.
The train that ended the war.
A trolley is quickly.
Approaching five people tied to the tracks.
You have the option to divert.
No, he had the butterfly effect.
Not that he's gotten another even more crazy dictator today.
over and then it will be your fault.
Okay.
Um, don't you believe in morally gray and redeemable
villains?
You could redeem that baby.
Surely.
Definitely.
Patch your rest suit.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What am I, Batman?
None of his villains were redeemable.
Um, you have the, they were cool, but they still killed
millions of people.
Um, you have the option to divert the trot into different
tracks, saving the five howard this will create a new
trolley problem not my problem
what would you not my problem if this is it's someone else's
problem there we go
what i mean that's your problem that's right you gotta deal
with that dilemma
problem is not mine not my trolley problem yeah double it
and pass it on to someone else a trolley is quickly
approaching people tied to the tracks you have the option to
divert the trolley to a free track you must redirect it to
avoid harming anyone can we reach their destination without
hurting more than five people also don't crash the trolley
that should be fine that seems pretty easy i just gotta make
sure it doesn't run over anyone there we go okay that goes
straight oh fuck okay i'm sorry um that's fine there were so
many tracks i got lost in the sauce okay and then we go here
and then we go down and then we go down again and then we go
up down and then up again who keeps tying all these people
up all right here all right down here oh my god who keeps
tying pds all these people up there you go must have been
look one casualty that's fine he didn't have his life ahead
of him anyway oh wait it's not over wait what do you mean
it's not over wait what do you mean i i thought i i finished
it there's more there's always more oh god oh god oh god
that's fine that's fine that's fine that's fine that's fine
two two deaths i mean i saved 20 people and i killed two
that's like probability wise like you know i take that's
okay that's okay
The zigzaggy and everything.
It's okay.
Alright, I'm thinking in the future now.
There we go.
And then up.
And then down.
And then up again.
And then up.
And then down.
I can go straight, right?
Yeah, nobody's going to.
gonna die here.
Here you go.
See, look at that.
I mean, I could have went up, but I didn't.
Oh, shit.
That's fine.
That's just one guy.
That's just, that's just one guy.
Think about the thousands I saved.
Think about it.
Think about the thousands of people I just saved.
not the four people I killed but the thousands of people I
oh just because I killed four people I'm the bad guy um
you're a conductor and your trolley is quickly approaching
five people tied to the tracks um you obviously have the
option to stop the trolley and save the five people however
you could also make the person next to that diversion lever
choose between letting Five people die.
We're actively killing one person.
Not my problem.
Like I said.
Like, why should I make this my problem?
Alright.
Your conductor.
Oh, wait.
If I save the five, I won't kill.
Oh, okay.
What do I do?
Oh, I'm the kill.
Oh, I could have just stopped it.
I mean, I guess.
Oh.
Why didn't that guy do anything?
Wait.
Because I thought he would do something.
Okay.
Okay, if I stop here, will I stop?
Oh.
I thought he would do something.
I didn't realize it was up to me right on top.
Take the trolley for a spin.
Travel to the city.
Pick up.
I also wanted a better view.
I wanted a better view to see if he'll stop it.
He made his choice.
I did not pull.
That's on him.
He killed five people.
I saw that.
He didn't pull the lever so I try to stop so in the end I
was the good these people will remember that he didn't pull
the lever Travel to the city pick up passages and take them
to their destination It's time to enjoy a nice trolley ride
Oh wait, I get to actually drive the trolley.
Oh my god.
It's the train simulator again How do I do this?
Okay, that's the break.
Okay, we gotta go forward
I saw two people still alive.
They're my witnesses.
Two were still alive.
Hello.
Oh, I didn't stop in in time.
Sorry, this is my first day on the job.
The other times I was doing a fucking trolley problem.
This is my first time actually driving the trolley.
All right.
Why are most beatubers even?
Thousands of people but oh I murdered like one or two and
suddenly I'm the bad guy Like that just makes me human.
It means I made a human error
I'm a real train conductor now
Oh guys, I'm gonna watch utopia today.
It's utopia too.
I'm so excited
I'm going to watch Zootopia 2 today.
All right, here you go.
All right, get in my train.
Get in my trolley.
Yeah, the second one came out today.
You know what's crazy?
Okay, apparently Zootopia is very, very popular and famous
in China.
That's why you see merch of it everywhere.
And that's why the Zootopia said, what is it called?
I forgot what is it?
Oh yeah, it's called Zootopia.
Zootopia called?
Zootopia.
That's why they made a real Zootopia in, um, is it like in
Shanghai Disneyland?
Yeah, it's very popular in China.
So that's why they built Zootopia in, in the Shanghai
Disneyland because of how popular Zootopia is.
And like, that's why you see merch of Judy and what's the
fox's name, Nick?
Everywhere.
Like he's, they're literally everywhere for merchandising
there um and um and the funniest thing is like you know how
apparently the main character is a snake one of the main
characters is a snake and he's the guy that did um the guy
that played the uh what was it called everywhere blah blah
blah i can't remember the movie title it's such a long title
um but you know that guy who got really famous um from that
one movie he did um but there's no merch of him anywhere
because snakes aren't cute and it's so sad There's no merch
of...
You can't find any merch of him anywhere.
Because like, people were like...
Like, the other animals are cuter.
I was like watching, like, a video of people...
Like, this guy was like, I'm gonna try and find my favorite
character.
Because he's my favorite actor.
And, like, trying to find a snake.
And literally, like, none of...
Like, there was no merch of him anywhere.
But he is literally the main...
The main character in the movie.
Like, the whole film is based off of his story.
That's crazy.
Hey, Doki.
My brother was recently kidnapped and last seen near some
trolley tracks.
Do you know anything about that?
I hope he's okay.
Nope, not my problem.
Thank you for this super chat kill.
Thank you, thank you.
That wasn't my...
Not my schedule for today, you know.
Not part of my schedule track.
You know how routes?
Not part of my route.
Sorry, bro.
Why?
Are we...
Oh, we got two more stations to go.
But I thought that was funny.
But no, Zootopia is like...
That's why you see, like, so much merch of Judy and...
Judy and Nick everywhere.
They're, like, so popular.
Wait, can I...
Oh, I didn't!
Wait.
Let's even say choo-choo.
It just goes ring-ring-a-ding-ding.
Ring-a-ding-ding.
It just goes ring-a-ding-ding.
Where is the other seat?
Oh, there it is.
I didn't even realize.
Oh, am I there?
All right, give me a sec.
There you go.
All right, students.
Marshall, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My god.
Thing is, I read...
Okay, that comic is wild.
I remember reading...
Okay, I won't fucking, like, be, like, ignorant.
I've read that comic when it first came out.
When it first, like, blew up in the internet.
And it first came out.
So, the plot for, like, the artist is...
That whole storyline is fucking wild.
Because, like...
Because, like, it's wild.
Like, she becomes, Judy, like, dumps Nick and then, like,
hooks up with a female fox or another fox, but she's, like,
a female fox.
But she was, like, like, like a hooker.
It's so, it's fucking wild.
It's such, it's so wild.
They all leave?
All right, here we go.
Yay, we did it.
The trolley solution.
Oh, is this the last level?
The year is 1967.
The trolley is quickly approaching five people tied to the
tracks.
You have the option to divert the trolley to a different
track where wouldn't British philosopher Philippa foot?
This would create a time paradox that would prevent the
trolley problem from ever existing.
Or you could do nothing and be cursed to solve the trolley
problem over and over again.
What would you do?
I break.
I continue he did this to us he did this to us I know what
to do the fact that it's a woman does not change my oh shit
oh no what happened oh I broke the cycle guys I did it
freedom I did it.
It must have been her.
She must have tied them all to the tracks.
Wait, what happens if I click start game?
There's no longer...
There's no more problems.
The last ride of the day?
a trolley is calmly approaching the terminal nothing needs
to be done nothing to solve nothing to worry about just
relax and enjoy what remains of the ride oh my god i did it
important guys that i can't believe this game i bought only
had one level guys i oh my sorry guys i'm sorry i picked I
thought this game would, I don't know, I really did think
that this game had more levels.
I can't believe it.
I booted up this game and there was only one level, guys.
What happened?
Like,
wow, the stream was only 10 minutes long.
At least it's coming.
The trolley had no problems.
two hours no i was talking to my chat for two hours and then
we went into the game and it was only one level straight up
just the trolley going down the track i can't believe i
watched only 30 minutes of cookie cooker patria said thank
you super chat thank you thank you the game tricked turkey
into paying much money to be a public transportation staffer
for two hours even a super chat thank you thank you but why
are there two oh what no what did i do what oh just because
i murdered a couple of people i deserve to to get murdered
too okay philosophic i mean 58 that ain't too bad this is
not that many also you killed a baby okay but that baby was
a bad baby.
There's no such, okay, I hate people who are like, people
who are like, you know, people who are like, look at how
cute my baby is, and it's an ugly baby.
Like, you gotta accept your baby's ugly.
Like, don't lie.
Because they give us a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, Doki.
I just had a thought.
Imagine a trolley approaching five people tied to the
tracks.
You're next to the lover.
I divert the trolley to the track with only one person tied
to it.
Would you pull up the, we gotta tie this guy to the track.
guys we got he got we have to tie he's thinking too hard get
him guys thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
look at that did nothing did nothing free will i like how i
said free will and i did nothing
yay free will i took mat look at that i'd use my free will
very well
Yeah, that was fun.
That was fun.
That was a little fun, a little one-off game.
A lot of things I did not expect to happen.
I like the, I think my favorite, I think my favorite problem
in the trolley problem was definitely the one where, like,
your girlfriend cheated on you, but on your best friend, but
then your best friend didn't know, and also your best friend
has cancer.
I was just like, what the fuck?
I think that one was the wild, that one was the hardest one,
and the most wildest question.
I was just like, oh, it keeps going on.
But also, how would my best friend not know what my
girlfriend looks like?
Like how did I never show, I, I'm, bro, if, bro, if I would
tell my best friend, like, bro, I hooked up with someone
last day.
Like, I would tell him or her, I would tell him, like, bro,
how would he not know?
like nah he definitely knew he fucking knew like sometimes
you just forget yeah your best friend was apparently also
blind but that was that was a really fun game oh i had a fun
time hanging out with uh my dragons uh with you guys and you
know going through a moral dilemma Emma.
We learned a lot about me today.
Look, okay.
I'll defend myself with the shopping cart.
If I see one of the teenagers, you know, when I do grocery
shopping and I see one of the teenagers like rolling around
in with their little car, I would leave the cart next to the
next to like the Uber car because I know that he's gonna
pick it up right after.
So what is the point of me cart shopping cart to i'm to to
the area where you park it i saw i see the kid heading over
anyway i see the kid i am defending myself i am the cart
narc is gonna get you you toky that is wrong this is the
worst thing you've ever done bro
I'm just making sure you know like you know I see them there
and then you're just a bad person it's not like I leave it
in the open like without anyone attending I see the kid
there and then I'd be like hey car and then I get in the
uber to Arkham prison with you I can't believe I'm someone
who would do that.
I feel so betrayed.
I'm shaking and crying right now.
We can forgive the murders, but the shopping cart, think
about the teenager.
Somehow that feels worse.
Okay.
Hey, guys.
I am gonna, I'm gonna call it here, guys.
I am gonna call it here.
I have I'll give you guys an update tomorrow on how how good
sutopia if sutopia 2 is good or not um, but don't worry
guys.
I'll give you guys an update.
I haven't been in a theater in a while So um, I don't know.
I haven't watched an animated film.
Okay.
It was either going to be wicked part 2 or sutopia 2 and
then I was just like I heard um wicked because like I
watched the first wicked in theaters.
I want to do like spoilers of the movie, but I did watch the
theaters, but I fucked up and watched it in, um, in 3D IMAX.
And that was like a bad mistake because the colors were
already like pretty bad.
I don't know if you guys know about the joke about, uh,
Wicked, but it feels like there's no color grading at all.
And everything is just dull as fuck.
And then you put on top of it wearing 3D glasses on top of
it.
Like all the colors are just super fucking dull and matted
um because the 3d glasses also like lowers the color like
darkens all the colors so it was it was like not a fun watch
for me just because everything was just so fucking dark um
so so i watched the first wicked because i do enjoy the
songs like i like i like the dancing tempana i like that
song and i like um i like uh what was the other one uh I
like that so that's why I watched it and then like the thing
is apparently in the second wicked movie um that's where
like the worst songs are in because all the good songs are
in the first part one because that's also like Broadway the
musical where part one had all of that and then part two is
where all the fucked up like part two is where it gets super
fucking messy and like no one know what the fuck is going on
um so that's what they did in the second movie as well so I
read the reviews and people were like yeah know wicked part
two is a little what the fuck like and like none of the
there's like there's like no there's apparently not a lot of
good songs in part two um and because of that because they
put they they put it all in part one so all the like
everything that people remember from wicked is from part one
and not from part two um but it's like people are saying
it's like more forgettable and then um and then uh how like
how like the scarecrow looks really fucking weird because
he's supposed to be like Fiero Fiero or some shit and then
he has to be like like the like apparently he looks like
Ryan Reynolds when he gets turned into a scarecrow like
that's what I heard people were like go bro what the
scarecrow looks like Ryan Reynolds like apparently people
are like laughing about it um um it has for good though yeah
one song do you how many songs they were in fucking part one
so so i was just like oh man do i watch the second wicked
movie or zootopia 2 and i'm like zootopia 2.
i was just like ah fuck yeah i watch i watch zootopia 2
because i was just like i want to watch a movie oh yeah yeah
so yeah i'll let you guys know if it's good or not.
And I get to see Shakira again.
Shakira.
That's right.
I'm watching it for Shakira.
Not for anyone else, honestly.
I don't really care about any of the other characters.
I'm here for Shakira.
Darkblade.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Surely the trolley problem doesn't show up in Sitopia too.
Peter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Watching you play this game was very entertaining.
I had a great time.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm glad you guys had a great time.
I know, right?
Finally.
I get to finally see Shakira again.
Ole, ole.
Hey, guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve
it.
Oh, also, also, for those who are talking about the May
Cafe, you can send only out.
Have you got a weekend slot?
If you have a weekend slot, and you can have...
have said give gifts but it has to be letters and postcard
size um there is like an faq on the website that says
exactly if you are going to go to the maid cafe it does say
like what type of gifts you're allowed to bring there is a
faq on there apparently um so uh and they said that gifts
should not exceed post the size of a postcard in length and
height and should be small enough to fit in an envelope.
Several items include postcards, letters, keychains, pins,
stickers, buttons, and small items.
So, no, you can do other items, but it has to be small
items.
So, you can give gifts, if only on weekends, only if you
have the weekend slots.
But yeah, that's what my manager said for those who were
there.
But yeah, anyway, guys, like I said, as always, everybody,
stay hydrated, pause, check, get up, and move around to get
that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everyone.
Bye guys.
Bye.